- He's a spiritual
leader and founder of the
Art of Living Foundation.
He teaches that spirituality
enhances human values
like love and enthusiasm.
For his service, he has received
some of the highest awards
from several countries.
He's Sri Sri Ravi Shankar
and here is my take
on his Top 10 Rules of Success Volume 2.
Rule number one is my personal
favorite and I'd love to know
which one you guys like the best.
And as always, as you're
watching, if you hear
something that really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below.
Put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired
as well and when you write it
down, it's much more likely
to stick with you as well.
Enjoy.
(upbeat music)
- Life is not flowery,
not buttery, I tell you.
So many challenges.
Life has so many challenges
but the wisdom and knowledge equips you
to face the challenges.
The difficulty is when you think life
should not have challenges.
Then challenges will appear
even much bigger to you.
Life has challenges but wisdom
equips you to face them.
Why do you want everything to be easy?
(audience laughs)
Take some challenge.
Challenges are necessary in life.
Don't you think so?
Everything is so easy, it is so boring.
See how people go up on
this mountain and jump
from the cliff with the hang glider.
It's a challenge.
Some people want to go
and scale Mount Everest.
Someone says, "Oh, I want
to sail through the world."
These are all challenges, people.
Take it.
Take some little small challenges in life.
How to deal with uncertainty.
Turn back and see your own life.
How many time you felt like that.
How many times you spend worrying
and things all happen right, right?
In the right manner.
So, looking back at your own experience,
you should say, "This is
futile to worry about it."
Yeah?
Second is,
you should have confidence
in your own ability
and in your own fortune.
You should know that only the
best thing will happen to me.
It'll happen to me.
That confidence.
If these two things doesn't
work, there's a third option.
Invoke the valor in you.
Tell it, come what may.
I will face it. I will handle it.
I have the power to handle it.
You know, spirituality is...
uplifting the spirit, your consciousness.
Money is for your comfort.
Money brings you comfort
in your material level.
You know, we are spending
half of our health
to gain wealth,
and then we spend half of our
wealth to regain the health.
It usually doesn't work.
So, taking care of your
health, because health is the
best wealth one can have,
is part of spirituality.
With money, I would say,
money should be kept in your
pocket, not in your head.
If you keep thinking
about money all the time
you can't even enjoy the
money that you have produced.
Money is needed but something
that is more necessary
than money is that humanness,
is that happiness
that money cannot buy.
Stop the mind, you know, it's racing.
It's always thinking about the past
or anxious about the future.
We are angry about the past
To take a fresh look at the
world, to the situation,
you need to wake up and see.
As Mahatma Gandhi used to say,
don't ever turn back and look.
Say now let's look and
see what we should do now
and for the future.
That gives a lot of energy,
encouragement, enthusiasm
and lifts you up from the ashes,
even though there are ashes.
Action has some imperfection.
Maybe 1% or 80% or 90%.
Some percentage of mistake
is always present in action.
When you notice it, you
recognize a wise man accepts
a mistake.
But a fool
doesn't see the mistake at all.
A fool can miss blunders
but doesn't see the mistake.
When someone points it
out, he doesn't accept it.
He becomes defensive.
This is what a fool does.
You know?
Wise man, if he sees mistake in others,
he helps them come out of it
in a compassionate manner,
but the fool takes pride
in other's mistake.
A fool is so happy if
someone else does a mistake
and he announces to the world,
"Look! That person did a mistake.
That person did a mistake."
We have some very talented
people but they have certain
mindless points.
If you look at the mindless
points, the talents
are gone.
Isn't it?
So, you don't see a very perfect person
but your intention is to
see everyone as perfect.
When you are looking for
perfection in everybody around,
I tell you, you forget to see
the imperfection inside of you.
We want everything else to be perfect.
Ah you mean the perfection.
You have to look for that.
When you see that you are perfect
you will stop pointing out
and get frustrated about
other's imperfection.
If we are frustrated about
other's imperfection,
we cannot contribute to
their growth.
They become imperfect.
This is the dilemma.
We want others to be perfect,
organizations to be perfect,
nations to be perfect,
people to be perfect,
and in this run, we
forget to see how we can
improve ourselves.
What do you say?
Right?
So when we start looking within,
a whole new dimension
opens in front of us.
Choice is never between good and bad.
There is no choice between water and sand.
If a cup of sand is
kept and a cup of water,
you do not say, "Which I want to drink?"
(audience laughs)
You will definitely drink water.
If the choice is only
between water and juice,
you drink whatever.
Both are necessary for life.
So, when you think which
I will get more joy,
your greed makes your
choice very difficult.
When you're not so greedy, say nevermind.
Now I will take water, little later juice.
(audience laughs)
You feel at ease with it.
There is no choice between
good and bad at all.
Once you know this is bad
you will never choose it
because it is bad.
So when you don't know it's good or bad,
then use your...
...sense,
that which gives you long term happiness.
Short term problems to be chosen.
That which uses short term
happiness and long term
problems should be discarded.
Got it?
So be in this world.
Enjoy this world,
yet, not get caught up,
drown in it.
Keep yourself a little alone.
I'm saying keep yourself
untouched by the external.
Save your soul.
Save your mind.
Save your spirit.
Save your joy.
Don't get that muddled by
the events in the world.
Are you getting what I'm saying?
Don't let others or any events
take away your freedom,
take away your joy,
and your inner peace.
This is how to feel.
You found new ways to clap.
Right?
In the same way,
in the world, in day to day life,
so many events come to
put down your enthusiasm
but never give up.
When you light a candle,
and put it upside down,
what happens?
Does the flame goes down or goes up?
Flame always goes up, right?
Like that, life is light.
Life is a burning flame.
You should see that it
should always go up.
Even there are 100 reasons to be unhappy,
we should overcome them all.
Who can do it?
Only you can do it.
Got it?
So, at no point, don't
give up your happiness
or your enthusiasm.
Now, what is a way to be happy?
By sharing happiness, spreading.
When you spread happiness, it grows.
When you don't spread
it, hold on to yourself,
it dwindles, dwindles, and then finishes.
This is what people don't know.
They want to be happy.
They don't know how to
share with everybody,
how to expand one's family.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know, what did
you take from this video?
What was the most important
lesson that you learned,
that blew your mind, that you're
going to immediately apply
to your life or your business somehow.
Please leave it down
in the comments below.
I'm super curious to find out.
Also, if you want to
nominate someone for the next
Top 10 video, please check
the description for a link
to a video where you can
votes for people and put in
your suggestions as well.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Vihan Gopinath.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
"Your One Word".
I really really really
appreciate the support
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.
- There are four ways
to deal with a person
who is doing things which you don't like.
Are you ready to listen to it?
First is, forgive them.
Okay.
Tell them don't do this again.
Okay, now it doesn't matter.
Anyway, it's happen, but
please don't do this again.
Gentle forgiveness.
Second time, when they do it,
you should show indifference.
You know indifference.
You repeated it, I'm not
going to accept this.
This is indifference.
Don't talk to me.
Third time they repeat,
you simply cut off, move away.
Take some distance.
If they repeat on the fourth time,
then you take a stick.
If your really want
what you are aiming at,
hold on to it.
You know?
But if you feel it is worthless
putting so much effort
and what am I going to achieve by that,
then you move on to something
which is much easier.
Yeah?
You know, once there was a
short term prime minister
in India.
He said, "Guruji, now I am
prime minister, I find for this
I struggled all my life.
I find it's meaningless.
Before I could sleep here happily.
See now there are 50 policeman guarding.
I can't even sit outside
my own home in the farm."
"Life is futile," he says.
"It's a futile struggle all my life."
I said, "Even to understand
this is took you so many years."
Anyway, at least, now you
realize many people don't even
realize at that time, what
is happening with all these
dictators and rulers,
in North Africa.
They're all killing thousands of people
just to hold onto power.
This is stupidity.
At least our gentleman
Indian prime minister had
this sense, it was futile game.
I said, "You are lucky, in this sense."
So like that, if you want
to really achieve it so hard
then put all your life to achieve it
but you find something else
is better to put your energy,
go in that direction.
You know India has a long
history of spiritual upliftment.
When you see that everything is collapsing
and all doors are shut
and there is no hope
and depression sets in and
I use a vision of, you know,
something higher and the possibility
and the power of your own
thought, the power of your mind
and how you can create
your reality or world
and move in that direction.
You may not be successful
immediately, tomorrow,
but the vision and the mission
always takes you forward.